some breaking news from turke now local
media are reporting that there has been
an explosion and gunfire in the heart of
the capital Anora this is near the
Parliament building that's the
information that we have for
now our correspondent SIM kosoglu can
join us on the phone cinim can you can
you add any details to this
picture uh good morning yes for now the
security measures have been tightened
around the Parliament building and the
interior Ministry building uh today is
the 1st of October and today uh the
Turkish Parliament which has a closed
sessions for summer uh is coming back on
track and uh all parliamentarians
including the president uh were expected
to be in the parliament in the afternoon
around uh 2:00 p.m. uh 2 K local time
and president Adon was expected to
deliver an opening speech for the
parliament right now what we know from
the sources is that the explosion
happened around 9:30 local uh which is
nearly one hour ago and in Ankara in the
capital all these buildings the
Parliament building the Parliament
building the Ministries they are settled
very close to each other and the
explosion is reported to have happened
uh close to the Parliament and interior
Ministry around kisai Square which is
the uh which is one of the uh most
prominent squares of the city uh two
consecutive explosions are being
reported right now and right after the
sound of the explosions H there were gun
fires uh according to the reports and
now the suspicions have focused on a
suicide bomb and on the Turkish TV
Outlets we are seeing reports that say
that there was a car parked outside the
interior Ministry building which was a
left out there actually uh apparently in
these areas uh you cannot park in front
of the ministry buildings you cannot
take pictures but there are suspicions
that uh collaborators might have uh
might have uh escaped after the sound of
the explosion but there is no official
report right now we are hearing that
anara security forces have uh sealed the
area they have taken uh the maximum
measures uh in order to uh not to missed
any details but uh what we know so far
is that two consecutive explosion sounds
and gunfire sounds right after that in
the heart of the capital Anar close to
the Turkish Parliament which was due to
open its fion today s what are the
groups or people if we're going to put
context around this that are capable and
have a track record of carrying out
attacks within on Turkish
soil looking at the recent history of
the country the Kurdistan Workers Party
the pkk uh has carried out uh missions
uh like this in the touristic areas in
the city centers in the capital anara uh
train station uh nearly 10 years ago
also uh there there are some other
leftist groups leftist leninist groups
that carry out such attacks and usually
the those kinds of uh organizations have
some
sub uh groups that are named as
terrorist groups by the Turkish security
authorities so far it is too early to
describe who has commented that but I
also have to underline that the Turkish
authorities have been have been carrying
out uh anti isol attacks anti isol
operations and have been capturing isol
members who H who who were in
preparation of attacks in Turkey some of
them are not reported on International
media because it has become a routine
they are doing operations against the
pkk AL Kurdistan workus party against
the isil against the uh gulenist
organization members so far as I said it
is too early but usually these kinds of
uh actions these kinds of
uh attacks have usually been carried out
the pkk or it's a urban Wing uh uh so
far but uh there is no official uh
record yet and uh now I'm seeing uh a
latest line by the Turkish interior
Minister Alaya who says uh there were
two uh terrorist members who carried out
uh uh an attack abond attack and two
police officers have been slightly
injured this is his words he just
tweeted on his official social media
account okay repeat that first line two
members carried out the attack what were
the words he used he said uh two
terrorists uh uh two terrorists have
carried out a bomb attack two police
officers have been slightly injured this
is what he said and he's also saying in
his tweet that one of the terrorist uh
was a suicide bomb and the other
terrorist was shot by the police uh has
been eliminated by the police in his
words does he say or do you have any
evidence or are you seeing on Turkish
media that there is a Manhunt
underway uh according to the reports the
police have sealed the area they are uh
they have taken maximum measures uh but
so far they are just reporting about two
people who carried out the attack one
has already killed himself as it was as
that person was this uh suicide bomber
and the other uh uh perpetrator has been
uh killed by the police officers
pending further information um so
pending further information and
obviously this is a rapidly developing
story this happened less than an hour
ago but pending uh uh any new
developments on this there is no Manhunt
underway uh since according to the
interior Minister and I'm repeating what
you just said here there was um one
person who was a suicide bomber would
therefore have died in the attack and
the other apparently was killed uh again
according to the uh Turkish interior
minister by uh Turkish law enforcement
do you know if the lawmakers going back
to what you said earlier that this is
near the Parliament building do you know
if the members of parliament were in the
building at the
time well I have since today is the
first day of uh the parliament NE
session uh the winter session uh there
were reports that some of the parliament
members lawmakers have already entered
inside the building because they have
offices inside but the major event major
opening event was supposed to be held in
the afternoon around uh 2: p.m. local
which is uh like nearly in 4 hours but
uh no one is injured it is not right in
front of the uh Parliamentary Building
or right in front of the Interior
Ministry building it is an area of
diplomatic missions and uh government
buildings so everywhere is close to each
other either you're right in front of
those buildings or very close to those
buildings but uh apparently in these
kinds of uh attacks during these kinds
of attacks there has always been uh a
man handun yes they are reporting about
two perpetrators one of whom has already
killed uh him or herself and the other
one uh being El being killed by the
police officers uh these kinds of uh
attacks are you know sometimes
coordinated close by some other people
and surely the police is uh right now
going after any possible perpetrator who
could have been in the field but there
were no words about this by the Turkish
authorities right now president erdogan
you say was supposed to address members
of parliament today that feels very
significant this is this is his plan
because this is the first day of the
parliament uh winter 2023 and as the
president he always delivers the speech
uh in the afternoon and uh I'm expecting
that that will uh definitely happen and
uh because the Turkish Parliament was
also bomb during the f p attempt in
2016 July 15
2016 the the Turkish Parliament building
was uh was attacked by the helicopters
and planes uh run run by the Buist
organization and H they do not they do
never prefer to shut down the parliament
apparently
we are going to see him delivering his
speech uh holding uh together with all
the uh lawmakers to show the solidarity
ER of the Turkish and the strength of
the Turkish parliament in the afternoon
today wait I want to make sure I
understand what you're saying there do
do we have information that that speech
by the president will indeed be going
ahead today do we know that yet uh the
the the since the attack has just
happened like in the last one hour
we don't have any information uh of a
cancellation or a continuation but no
knowing the nature of the Turkish
politics and knowing the nature of the
politicians Behavior especially Turkish
president re ton one should expect that
he will definitely deliver his speech
yeah I understand and and by the way
we're looking at the the pictures uh it
appears that the bomb squad is on the
scene um there so we're talking about
anchor let me reset I have some more
questions for you CN but let me reset
it's 7:22 GMT it is uh just before 10:30
local time in anchora and just around
9:30 so that's less than an hour ago
explosions were heard Turkish media is
reporting that explosions were heard in
Anora uh in the area where there are
embassies government buildings that is
close to the Parliament and a notable
fact that our correspondent uh CM kogu
who's on the line with us has just been
reporting is that today is the opening
of the Parliamentary session of this
year's parliamentary session and as a
result of that members of parliament
some of them had already made their way
in the building C I'll have another
question on that on that for you in just
a second and also importantly the
Turkish president recently reelected
Turkish president rev Ty
erdogan was maybe still is scheduled to
address lawmakers in that very building
not very far from where a gunfire Was
Heard and then a bomb or perhaps two
bombs went off now the latest
information that we're getting from
official sources the Turkish interior
Minister was saying that two
attackers um carried out suicide attacks
in front or getting an update on the
exact location in front of the Interior
Ministry one of them uh died in the
suicide attack the other one was quote
neutralized by Turkish police uh two
policemen were injured in the
attack and police have since cordoned
off the area that's what you're seeing
now they closed the roads the bomb squad
that we just saw is searching the area
to see if there are any other explosives
that's what we know 50 minutes after
this all occurred in anchura aljazira
cinam kolu is with us C is there
anything that I've missed is there
anything you want to add to that picture
definitely this is what we have so far
as you have also reported uh at first it
was reported that there W there was an
explosion but then later after
especially the interior Minister's tweet
uh we understood that there were uh
there were two uh explosion sounds and
according to his tweet those two in his
words two terrorist members uh have have
a arrived at the scene with a Light
commercial vehicle one of the uh
perpetrators already H killed himself as
as that person was a suicide bomber and
the other perpetrator was killed by the
Turkish police this is the only
information we have so far but uh these
kinds of uh attacks in Turkey these are
sensitive situations the the authorities
usually try to be very careful to avoid
any kind of um misunderstanding than uh
any kind of flashbacks but so far what
uh what we know they're talking about
two perpetrators the bomb Scots are in
the scene the police have sealed the
area uh uh very deeply and um yes uh the
interior Minister once again underlined
that uh turkey will continue to fight
against uh terrorism until the last
terrorist uh has been eliminated uh this
is like the slogan of the Turkish
security authorities as the country has
fought against uh terrorism for a
decades and have lost many security
forces and many civilians this is what I
want to ask you about anybody switching
on their television right now watching
this will want to know two things
they'll want to know what happened I
think we just established everything
that we know for now but they will also
want to know who's behind this to be
very clear we can't we can't directly
answer that question now we do not have
that information everyone everybody can
understand it is way too early to give a
definitive answer what we can give is
the context of who has carried out
attacks in Turkey in the recent past
we're going to break soon but can you
give us just briefly again who has
attacked turkey
before sure of course uh in turkey and
in the last maybe four decades there
have been many attacks carried out by uh
several groups including the outload
Kurdistan Workers Party the pkk uh the
pkk also has different Wings actually
they have a special Wing that carries
out these kinds of attacks in the city
centers because the fight against the
fight against the pkk had always been
conducted by the military in the rurals
but also there are Urban attacks also
there are some other leftist groups and
also we have seen ISO within the last
couple of years carrying out attacks in
uh Turkish tourism areas mainly in
Istanbul so there are many possibilities
on the table right now but we have we
have no information confirming that back
to you all right many thanks aljazera CM
coolu there for walking us what we know
less than an hour after an attack was
carried out in central anchora that's in
turqu on the near the Parliament
building on the day that the
Parliamentary session was scheduled to
re open and that the president RP Ty
erdogan was scheduled to address
lawmakers that's what we have for you
for now on alra
zer